previously on human fall flat seems like
I could fall off at any moment not a
great club what's the point Bob what's
the point
dreams don't know wait don't take this
from me why would you do it for us this
is for us no wait don't please don't
[Applause]
I think he was really gonna have it I
was you know I was I think I believe I
think you were it was very clear I had
here let's just move this way buddy it's
okay it's okay buddy mark you owe me
break this lock he won't hear you know
what you do it buddy
you earned it no way did you hurt me
today you've hurt me in ways I didn't
know I could be hurt I can't believe
you'd do that the pain in my soul you're
being so dramatic right now mark you
know that it didn't happen to you Bob
dude he did it to me too he did the
exact same thing to both of us oh yeah
where's the highest mountain I can jump
off here wait mark I can Ram you through
this is this this is like a cool spear
thing to die yeah let me entail me
impale why isn't it turning turn here
I'll be I'll be wherever the pointy end
is just know I saved him I tried to kill
mark leave me alone
let me die no that's just my bad it's
harder to a that you'd think it's harder
to have
move towards where it's going to be
turning it's really close backwards okay
that'll definitely be better you know
what I think I need to reset my grip
okay please in the face you're nagging
me now
oh I'll save him don't worry let me go
let me go these stairs that's not what
you want to see but it'll work and I'll
catch you I'll catch you I got it didn't
work it it didn't work the climbing so
I'll give you some time you're not ready
to fly this was ahead of wasting time
put me the catapult launch me please
alright alright alright finally a way to
die alright okay oh my god you went over
it damn it nice work baby
there you go Bob can you both get in it
and trigger it while you're in there oh
yeah climb in here and then just smack
the handle yes this will work right
it'll work so that's almost it oh wait
wait can I do the thing oh wait no I
could just get to the other ones no no
I'm an idiot I thought this was special
I thought if it was like you didn't
break the wall you could get to agree
but no though you're right I mean you're
totally right that would be clever game
design I guess these developers
obviously subbed myself oh no wait a
minute oh my god can someone come grab
me
Wade you can always count on him
grabbing yeah cuz this is a go ah there
you go one block at a time
dude there's a door here dude
pump dude by plum dude this door I can't
get it up in here we got a door oh my
heart's being blown I mean I want to
follow in your footsteps mark my mind's
blown wait oh my god no there's stairs
right here I look upon you peasants
entering my castle my castle with my
name on it hang on I can use this haha
okay I prefer there was an easier way in
the net what whatever wait wait why this
fall wait mark where's this super secret
door bro yeah yeah yeah I am saving you
I don't think that's true
doors open the way is clear can we push
this together where are you guys going
oh you see guys guys guys guys guys
binding oh good thinking mark I open the
door yeah let's use the cart no guys the
door look I did it I did the thing I
want to ride it
cool good oh wait bringing the cart over
here oh here Bob the doors open now I
made it across oh hey Mark I think I
picked the optimal way to handle this
cart hang out a minute I'm not trying to
kill him I'm not petty like that yeah
I'm not petty I'm not petty you know
wait is his weight does and it's all
haha that's all art or am i bringing
this cart just over here by this rooftop
of that plank working out for you mark
worked up great but your carts obviously
way better and I would never belittle
any of your efforts so I don't imagine
you would belittle mine you do great
work dude
thank you I wasn't talking to you and I
don't think I ever will but good to know
what I'm in the water is that good oh no
apparently not knocked me off you dick
I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry I'm sorry than
I was trying to get out of the way get
one swing back do need one swing so what
multiple swings are for babies we know I
guess I'm baby God how did I make that
better watch it no please help me
grab my head take my hand take my head
I'll owe you a life debt
please gotcha do I have you let go of
your hand on my head grab on there we
will both lick of yeah and then we'll
both go up we got this yes yes yes yes
I don't think you have be come on listen
there we go
you go first buddy you earned it you go
ahead alright thank you Bob were you it
you need a night why not Tim figuring it
out you know all right I did it
I've done it hey Mark you said that lamp
back where what oh yeah it's coming back
very slowly with this part I can't
believe you struggled with hey I'm
pulling a block thing over here where
your sister meant you're meant to drive
it yeah trust me don't drive is it just
to get on the roof no this is to get
across somewhere are you still pulling
wait which way are we going I was gonna
go I think we might need it over here
looking at where mark set whoa
do we even need oh I see what you're
doing here you got to put in between
these so you can jump across this gap or
you guess you could just climb on that
building over there through the lamp all
right guys I got this huge thing by
myself you drive it all by yourself
logically speaking can't believe you're
struggling with it do you want me to
push or pull
I may have been too far I didn't know
that could happen it was unaware
we've gone keep going wage I feel like
you're really not helping alright there
we go there we go if we lose mark it's
alright wait we just need to make sure
my gosh guys good turn the other way
wait turn are we under we I think we're
uh yeah yeah no more no more stop this
is where we stop this is where the
stopping happens we we did around cool
good whatever is happening now is not us
also I have an idea I'm gonna go back a
little bit well if I just feel like this
can you can you oh my goodness guys have
you you can do it nope not quite you
need to go a little lower
mmm oh that's that's the rock that's the
rock oh oh oh that's your right hand is
on my head right now you let go your
left hand there's a lamp you there's a
lamp
the last lamp lets you it swings around
yeah this is gonna work so well guys I'm
gonna get in position to help if it
doesn't beautiful nevermind I'm in
trouble okay one of you just pull me up
the roof or something wait actually
let's do it on this end because you can
stand on you know if you climb up on the
wheel you can stand on the wheel and
just get me that doesn't make any sense
wait why are you so aggressive with your
wobbles and we go wait let me go you
can't do it wait I don't need it okay I
do need help actually thank you
life-debt I was trying to find tackle
one of you is that a hook hook hook
swing
[Laughter]
Oh save you save you
yeah oh well interesting but I did the
hook part good it was the didn't stick
the landing
hey wave got me a cross in time look at
us well you guys just took the rock up
enough you got what you need there way
alright let's go up this is for but this
might help you guys somehow good blog
okay cool oh yeah that'll work
that's walkable right oh my god no
that's working all right Wade you ready
yo inkum you're great
yo ur the hamster wheel over the hamster
wheel we're gonna hook this on there
well spin the hamster lower the rock all
right you know what I meant I don't know
I never know what you must my favorite
kid rocks on lower the hamster wheel
grab sorry I have to lower the rock it's
definitely good oh my god for good
reason what you didn't think it was
doable well I didn't say that okay I
didn't see mark smarter than the rest of
us thank you thank you
somebody said it thank you I've been
doing it I came in here first I'm
smarter than the rest
of you well by my own rules that's true
and just am not the rules giveth and the
rules taketh away are we supposed to
roll a barrel we must have been supposed
to like lay it down and then give it a
little shove a Rooney yeah
well that looks right go catch it go
catch a Bop never mind I'm here to catch
it I mean that was up I got it I'm the
best done I'm so goddamn great good work
Highway yeah okay you know what I'm not
bitter
I'm not a bitter vengeful person is this
really the right window apparently no
that's terrifying I don't like that at
all no did you not make it you need it
oh I need a hand all right
we kind of lost the barrel so don't [ __ ]
up anymore it feels so good to be so far
ahead yeah yeah yeah ooh you want to
spin the wheel don't want to hit a Xango
hmm a really good wheel spinner wait we
got I'm gonna try to jump around you
there seems to be something going on
here wait what's this all about
what's all this nonsense this is a place
huh yeah wait is this where we're
supposed I'm still way back here doing
weird stuff oh did I just go backwards
Oh God I did
um this is not what this is supposed to
do I found the blacksmith guys gone
oh that's like a you mean I lived oh I
died life is cruel like oh come on
I hate this oh hey Mark Waid get it get
it get it for me do it for me you didn't
do it at all
I did it exactly as I did before only
wrong or I just grabbed it yeah what is
it gonna come off yeah are you guys over
at the end maybe oh wait for me I'm
alive I'm alive you probably don't want
to be that alive Wow your chin cut
alright there's nothing down here where
does this even go room for two
yeah it doesn't really go anywhere so
I'm gonna swing friend swing swing swing
wait oh wait wait we only need to go to
the ledge over yonder way yeah this way
you guys need some assistance from a
hook don't worry Bob
[Music]
you're right this couch slam the hell
down people pay a lot of money for that
Wow slam like I've seen some bad ones
but that one quality good slam you don't
make that jump is the thing oh I'm back
here now guys you're gonna love this
we're gonna why are we gonna love this
I'd already hate it you're gonna love
this
did you make it over already mark to you
oh my god you actually got it what a
wizard I got it wait we don't see where
your stupid person that you are are the
windmill blade that's dumb he's dumb Wow
I think I can make this jump it feels
like I can make this jump I mean I
didn't make it but I'm close wait mark
where are you I thought this is where
you were going
I'm on the ledge exit one of these is
home get sucked in you must wait for I
got this that's oh I'm not dead well
this is a different setting what are you
doing are you still trying to make the
jump off the windmill no I'm at the
blacksmith what where where's
where's the blacksmith all right we're
not in on the joke okay just because
it's a you meme doesn't mean we all like
it Smith
maybe I'll find the blacksmith whoa this
is a different setting what's going on
down here
why do that bring this bucket did you
come in my fuel yeah oh I know why I
brought oh hey what's up dude because I
am the best you can't beat him die a
horrible painful death shut up I'm the
best
what don't what the best is playing oh
god okay pop you didn't tell me about
the falling pillars ooh I didn't know
about the falling pillars I may have
done that I may have started that train
of events accidentally how's it going
down here guys
great I think you mean how's it going up
where we are winners hello oh my god
it's Lord of the Rings in here that
didn't that's the first time I
experienced that myself the last one
before it just did it is this gonna work
[Laughter]
grab your face I think I got it hey
buddy I know oh oh wait wait jump on
this wait cuz jump on this oh you
probably know about it but I'm coming
with you I face playing it pretty hard
[Laughter]
all three of us can get in this I bet oh
yeah let's do that we can totally do
this little butt I've ever seen dang it
ah don't force me out hang on
all right all right
[Applause]
Oh interesting hi Mike you can just hop
around
I gotcha
you don't I don't work weights being is
I'm one up - come here little guy never
embodied the Three Stooges more than in
this case good solid grasp on there for
two seconds do we need to bring
something to climb up there just right
one of us has to make it all right
teamwork everybody I can't believe that
worked a little bit it's a miracle
yeah this is the exit oh oh come on guys
I believe in us okay well before you go
Wow okay
oh he's still in a position where it can
help I think okay all right is I'm gonna
grab here and we'll bring my head up and
if you can grab my head get him get him
Wade you can do this there you go there
you go
you just like grabbed my ass I know how
this works
wait can you dangle your legs on this
side and maybe I'll grab your legs and
then you shoot myself again looks like a
really tall guy oh dammit what's going
on with his camera okay okay how do I
pull the lever okay
very high angle to see for a spider-man
kiss oh my god it was never to be
repeated never to be unfortunately maybe
your arm is joint oh oh what it's fine
we live together this and teamwork no
it's fine
no no no remember you Oh Bob and I
another life debt all right that's fair
[Music]